even the news that is true is fate
president Trump Illustrated this point
just the other day he was giving a press
conference he was sitting with Governor
Ron de Santos of Florida and a reporter
was insistent that the numbers the data
were so much worse than Trump was
suggesting it was then it turned out
guess what Yahoo News got the data wrong
Correa has done five times more tests
than the US per capita why is that I
don't think that's true that is true
when you said this morning the White
House said the u.s. passes South
Carolina's virus testing who are you
with Yahoo News we'll be looking at this
I just want to make it clear that South
Korea's testing was 11 per and we're at
17
well no but based on the numbers that I
had which are obviously completely
fictional and just came out of my
imagination it turns out you've done
terrible job mr. president yeah but what
about the actual numbers from the data
no no but look I didn't do anything
wrong even though I completely lied I my
numbers could not have possibly been
more wrong but I said them and I'm
wearing a suit and tie and I'm the very
serious mainstream media so I'm not
going to apologize I love the way Trump
handles it here says yeah you're gonna
you know dr. brig is what is he now
right Trump it's not like Trump has all
of the data right in front of him at any
given moment so he says I don't think
those numbers are right buster but I
don't know okay I guess we'll go check
them dr. Burke says no I've got them
right here the numbers are not right you
guys oh yeah your fake news this is why
no one listens to you that's why no one
pays attention to you because you're the
lying fake news why did I even think
otherwise and dr. Burke is trying to be
like the nice mom kind of there she's
like okay well just maybe you know next
time check the numbers Trump is like
yeah you're a liar and no one should
ever pay attention to you again and
that's true of the entire mainstream
media apparatus